ein schein strom etwa zeit einspruch der
podcast der die woche neu verhandelt ja
hallo liebe hörerinnen und herzlich
willkommen tsum faz einspruch podcast
folge nummer 7 vom zehnten januar 2018
auch heute wieder mit mir constantin von
leighton diesmal aber nicht mit corinna
budras diewald wie schon angekündigt im
wohlverdienten urlaub wird aber würdig
vertreten von markus jung ja mag ist es
ebenfalls redakteur bei der faz hier in
der wirtschaft tätig und markus sagt den
verein doch vielleicht ein zwei worte
dazu wer du eigentlich bist und warum
man die er zu rechtsthemen dringend zu
hören sollte ja vielen dank konstant
benutzt gerne das wort ist du auch schon
von ein paar wochen im ersten podcast
hier benutzt hast vom desertierten
juristen nach dem zweiten staatsexamen
also auch gewissermaßen auch die seite
der medien gewechselt als
gerichtsreporter gearbeitet und dann
münchner merkur auch hier im haus
geschrieben und dann ebenso wie du und
da gibt es eine parallele zwischen uns
beiden lange jahre in köln arbeitete war
den kollegen von lte und hört sich bei
den kollegen von juve und jetzt seit
oktober 2016 in der wirtschaftsredaktion
für juristische themen und auch für
gerichtsprozess berichterstattung
mitverantwortlich ja wunderbar
wir beide werden reichweite also ein
paar dinge erzählen und zwar zu den
folgenden vier themen als erstes soll es
um das bundesverfassungsgericht gehen
welches sich eine reihe von regeln zu
ethischem verhalten selbst auferlegt hat
wie es dazu kommt was der anlass ist was
da drin steht und warum man das für
nötig befunden hat in karlsruhe darüber
werden sich uns gleich unterhalten
als zweites blicken wir dann auf eine
entscheidung in sachen lkw kartell haben
mehrere hersteller die preise
abgesprochen und jetzt machen die käufer
dieser beteuerten lkw
schadensersatzklagen geltend sodann
blicken wir nach luxemburg wo morgen die
revisionsverhandlung gegen die beiden
ehemaligen pwc mitarbeiter beginnt deren
enthüllungen die sogenannten
fuchs links überhaupt erst ermöglicht
haben und zu guter letzt wird es noch um
eine entscheidung des bundesgerichtshofs
in sachen
vaterschaftsanfechtungsverfahren vaters
und das wird insbesondere in mir anlass
zu einer kleinen wutrede über die in
diesem bereich geltende und wie ich
finde sehr diskriminierend gegenüber
männern nämlich in diesem fall
tatsächlich mal diskriminierende
rechtslage geben nun aber zunächst nach
karlsruhe zum bundesverfassungsgericht
da war vergangenes jahr schon
angekündigt worden auf der
jahrespressekonferenz die laden immer
einmal im jahr eine reihe von
ausgewählten journalisten ein und
erzählen den immer so ein paar dinge die
dann für das kommende jahr bevorstehen
die spannend werden könnten und was
sicherlich am meisten aufsehen erregt
hat war die ankündigung dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht beabsichtigt
sich einen eigenen verhaltenskodex
aufzuerlegen den die richter dann
befolgen sollen
der ist jetzt so ein klein bisschen
klammheimlich an die öffentlichkeit
geraten es hat gar keine
pressemitteilung dazu gegeben sondern
der stand schwuppdiwupps auf einmal auf
der homepage des gerichts
und ja markus was denkst du denn bevor
wir gleich vielleicht zu den
eigentlichen inhalten dieses kodex
kommen was der grund gewesen sein könnte
warum man irgendwie die notwendigkeit
empfand sowas zu verfassen
wie du schon gesagt hat im vergangen
jahr gab es mehrere anlässe über ethik
regeln für richter nachzudenken und auch
mehrere medien haben das aufgegriffen
sicherlich erster anlass war eine kleine
anfrage der grünen im bundestag
da ging es darum eigentlich mal
herausfinden wieviel bundesrichter all
seinen verschiedenen bundesgericht ist
er gibt in deutschland neben
verfassungsgerichts das brg in erfurt
das bundessozialgericht wir reden aber
auch über den bundesfinanzhof in berlin
habe ich noch einmal vergessen ja denn
auch unseres gericht zuvor des
gerichtshof und bundesverwaltungsgericht
natürlich in leipzig also kommen da noch
ein paar zusammen und da hat man dann
nachgefragt wie viel verdienen dann
eigentlich noch zusätzlich zu ihrem
grundsalär man muss dazu wissen nach den
beamten besoldungsgesetz wonach sich ja
auch das gehalt der richter gestern
bundesgerichten verdienen die ohne
zuschläge zulage entschuldigung 115000
euro im jahr
und jedenfalls diese kleine anfrage
ergab dass im schnitt jeder
bundesrichter im schnitt 30.000 euro
zusätzlich pro jahr verdient das hat für
ein bisschen protest gesorgt
allerdings mit und zwar durch
verschiedene kleine manche geben ja zum
beispiel noch irgendwelche kommentare
heraus andere
neben bezahlte redner einladungen an
veranstalten irgendwelche seminare das
ist auch nicht verboten ist
grundsätzlich kann das auch legitim und
sinnvoll sein aber es hatte so ein
bisschen ein geschmäckle was glaube ich
noch zu deutlich mehr aufregung geführt
haben dürfte war die tatsache dass die
ehemalige bundesverfassungsrichterin
hohmann dennhardt dann ja ein gutes ja
nur bei vw tätig war anschließend wieder
ausschied und dafür ich weiß 11 12
millionen irgendwie sowas in der
größenordnung jedenfalls bekommen hat
auch das ist völlig legal aber wurde
halt irgendwie als etwas anrüchig
empfunden und dann gab es noch ein
weiterer punkt der hat jetzt erst einmal
nicht so viel mit geld zu tun aber
vielleicht eher mit einmischung in den
politischen prozess der ehemalige
präsident des bundesverfassungsgerichts
hans jürgen papier hat nach seinem
ausscheiden eine ganz bemerkenswerte
laufbahn als universal gutachter zu
allen möglichen rechtsfragen hingelegt
auf die eben auch zu sehr politisch
kontroversen fragen
das gleiche wer war das noch mal der die
sache dafür bayern begutachten sollte
papier vielleicht doch noch ein kontext
erwähnen dass das im letzten jahr ja
auch gutachten waren wirklich relevanten
entscheidungen atomausstieg tarifeinheit
gesetz das sind zwei sehr prominente
fälle ja und bayern hatte ja auch mal
begutachten lassen ob eigentlich eine
klage gegen die bundesregierung wegen
ihrer flüchtlingspolitik aussicht auf
erfolg hätte dies bejaht hat dann das
gutachten eines weiteren ehemaligen
bundesverfassungsrichters nicht papier
sondern wer war das noch gleich ist wie
wenn ich sicher weiß ich ob es jetzt die
verbio die verbio war es doch genau mehr
viele nur der name nicht ein aber so
sagt wenn ich mir sicher dass alles ist
wie gesagt erlaubt aber
dann wurde als etwas schwierig empfunden
und ich glaube wenn man das
verfassungsgericht das
bundesverfassungsgericht genießt ja in
deutschland ein unheimlich guten stand
in der bevölkerung in umfragen die wenn
es darum geht wie sehr vertrauen die
bürger den verschiedenen institutionen
des staates dann liegt das bei uns auch
das gericht immer wahnsinnig weit oben
so kopf an kopf rennen mit dem
bundespräsidenten weiter dahinter kommt
die politik und übrigens leider auch die
medien sowie so ist es und diesen
schönen ist-zustand er möchte man aber
auch gerne bewahren
sicherlich auch mit blick in die in den
europäischen osten wo die
verfassungsgerichtsbarkeit jahr an
verschiedenen fronten gewaltig kriseln
deshalb hat man sich sozusagen schon
vorbeugend jetzt diese insgesamt 16
regeln selber auferlegt die wir nicht
alle vorlesen werden aber was sind denn
so was wir zu den sagen sind vielleicht
die die interessantesten punkte daraus
ich glaube am wichtigsten das sollten
wir es einmal vertiefen sind die
transparenzregeln die sie die
amtierenden verfassungsrichter sich ja
selbst geben
also was um die tatsächliche tätigkeit
neben der richtertätigkeit geht
ich denke wir sollten über die
sogenannte karenzzeit reden oder was man
in der wirtschaft auch als cooling down
periods gerne bezeichnet das sind
eigentlich finde ich die beiden großen
entscheidenden punkte diese karenzzeit
wie ist die ausgestattet ein jahr glaube
ich noch und zwar ein jahr in dem man
was nicht tun soll
es ist so dass man innerhalb eines
jahres nach dem ausscheiden nicht als
berater gutachter oder auch als anwalt
in der sache die dezernat die das
dezernat dass man früher betreut hat und
auch mögliche folge entscheidungen
betreffen von entscheidungen den mann
involviert als richtig dass man da
selbst nochmal bundesverfassungsgericht
auftritt oder
öffentlich zu einer meinungsbildung
beiträgen das war vorher nicht so der
fall
man muss sich das vor allem bei du hast
schon erwähnt wo man denn noch mal
vergegenwärtigen die ist im januar 2011
ausgeschieden
um dann kurz darauf direkt bei daimler
in dem compliance und recht ressort
vorstand zu werden ähnliche rolle hat
sie dann entweder volkswagen ausgeführt
es geht vor allem darum
verfassungsrichter nochmal nach ihrer
eigentlichen tätigkeit ein bisschen noch
mal rauszunehmen und zurecht sachen die
in ihrem dezernat anhängig waren
übrigens da sollen sie dann auch gar
nicht tätig werden das ist also zum
beispiel ein teil dessen was jetzt
beschlossen worden ist da hat es eben
noch einen anderen aspekt angesprochen
denen vielleicht auch noch einmal
vertiefen sagt da steht denn wir sind
bei der karenzzeit glaube ich relativ
weit hinten in den regeln eingestiegene
vorne steht tatsächlich das offenlegen
von vergütungen und transparenz zu
wahren man muss da vielleicht noch mal
kurz zu sagen
die kleine anfrage der grünen da ging
natürlich nicht daraus hervor
wer wo wie viel verdient hat es wurden
also keinen namen genannt
ich glaube das ist unmittelbare reaktion
darauf dass man zumindest in den plenums
der gerichte jedem fall befassen
karlsruhe auch einschätzen kann wie viel
ein kollege der zusätzlich verdient und
diese nebeneinkünfte um das vielleicht
ein kleines bisschen greifbar zu machen
die kommen auf verschiedene weise
zustande beispielsweise irgendeiner
gesellschaft lädt einen
bundesverfassungsrichter eine rede zu
halten oder irgendein arbeitskreis das
ist wie gesagt prinzipiell legitim dass
dient vielleicht sogar mehr noch jetzt
bei den anderen bundesgericht beim
bundesverfassungsgerichts hof den
einschlägigen juristen durchaus auch
dazu sich so ein ungefähres
vorstellungsbild davon verschaffen wie
bestimmte rechtsfragen an
bundesgerichten gesehen werden ohne
natürlich dass die richter dort also
konkret zu sagen würden passt mal auf
wenn jetzt rechtsfrage xcom dann
entscheiden wir auf jeden fall
folgendermaßen das wäre sicherlich zu
viel und findet auch nicht aber es
vermittelt natürlich diese dieser
auftritte die dann eben auch von
entsprechend in den entsprechenden
bereichen tätigen juristen besucht
werden die vermitteln natürlich schon
ein ungefähres stimmungsbild an den
bundesgerichten und das ist wie gesagt
nicht grundsätzlich verkehrt ist aber es
ist sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt wenn
man wie das jetzt in das
bundesverfassungsgericht tun möchte da
transparenz schafft und offenlegt wer
wann was wofür bekommen habt ja ich was
man vielleicht noch dazu sagen sollte
das ist hier soft law diese regeln das
ist jetzt kein gesetz oder so es gibt ja
auch keine dienstaufsicht über dem
bundesverfassungsgericht also das ist
selber ja logischerweise
verfassungsorgan und da ist also keiner
der jetzt irgendwie hingehen könnte und
sagen könnte pass mal auf lieber
voßkuhle ich unter sage dir künftig mehr
als 4000 euro zu verdienen oder da und
dort aufzutreten aber ist schafft
natürlich trotzdem für die amtierenden
und auch für die ausscheidenden richter
sicherlich einen starken anreiz sich
daran zu halten weil es eben einfach
dann öffentlich sehr negativ aufgefasst
werden würde wenn jemand damit berichten
das sagte jetzt schon auch für doch sehr
kontroverse kritik
wie du schon gesagt hat es gibt keinen
der sagt was hat dann eigentlich eine
freiwillige selbstverpflichtung für
folgen wo es ist da wo sie zwar mit
einer gegenseitigen kontrolle aus und
auch sanktionierungen die sucht man da
total vergebens im letzten punkt heißt
es sinngemäß dass wenn ein mitglied über
das angemessene verhalten der bewehrung
der verhaltens leitlinien das hätte man
vielleicht noch sagen soll das ist der
offizielle titel dieses ethikkodex
verhaltens leitlinien und ihrer etwaigen
fortentwicklung etwas zu sagen hat dann
kann er das im plenum sagen
mit anderen worten wenn jemand mit dem
verhaltens leitlinien oder dem verhalten
eines kollegen nicht zufrieden ist dann
muss er das vor allem an
bundesverfassungsrichtern tun und dann
werden die innerhalb ihres plenums zu
entscheidungen kommen es gibt also
keinen wie durch schon gesagt hast
übergeordnetes kontrollgremium nochmal
und ja das versteht nicht jeder in
diesem land ja allerdings muss man auch
dazu sagen es ist ja jetzt nicht so als
wäre es in der vergangenheit wirklich zu
irgendwelchen klagen missbrauchsfällen
gekommen und so sich dann überhaupt eine
wenn auch in diesem fall rechten weiche
aber eben trotzdem eine
selbstverpflichtung aufzuerlegen
hätte man nicht tun müssen hat man getan
insofern finde ich das erste mal ein
ganz positiven schritt und da jetzt
wirklich noch eine mit rechtlichen
befugnissen ausgestattete
kontrollinstanz zu schaffen
das tut glaube ich nicht not oder dazu
hat die vergangenheit jetzt bisher keine
hinreichend klaren anlass gegeben
insofern also bundesverfassungsgericht
ist um seinen guten ruf
bemüht und möchte den jetzt mit diesen
leitlinien fördern so viel würde ich
sagen zu diesem thema ich glaube wir
kommen zum nächsten zum lkw kartell
nämlich da steht es um den beruf einiger
beteiligter unternehmen glaube ich
erheblich schlechter wer sind sie denn
und was ist da überhaupt sofort ein
realist ich denke man muss da
tatsächlich das kind direkt beim namen
in einem fall die beteiligten
unternehmen ist eine gruppe von
nutzfahrzeughersteller lkw-herstellern
die beginnt mit den volvo renault dfs co
die zu viert gehören es kann ja und
heime die sollen über jahrzehnte hinweg
nicht nur die fortentwicklung und
gegenseitige wettbewerb miteinander
abgesprochen haben sondern ganz konkret
auch preise was dann wiederum zu lasten
von den käufer natürlich geht und dann
reden wir natürlich über illegale
preisabsprachen und das ruft natürlich
die wettbewerbshüter auf den plan
na ja also das muss man dazu sagen es
ist jetzt nicht jede form der
kommunikation zwischen wettbewerbern am
markt untersagt man kann sich so in
hinblick auf technische entwicklungen
und und programmatik auch in gewissen
grenzen durchaus mit einer note erhalten
aber die eine sache die auf jeden fall
gar nicht geht und in ganz klassischen
prototypischen teil des rechtsverstoßes
darstellt ist eben wenn man preise
miteinander vereinbart das haben die
offenbar getan wie ist das ans licht
gekommen wenn man kann das relativ gut
konstruieren weil die eu-kommission
setzt da schon seit jahren auf ein
anreizsystem das nennt sich der
sogenannte kronzeugen programm also
einer der beteiligten kartellanten
offenbart sich bei der
wettbewerbsbehörde sei es jetzt in bonn
beim bundeskartellamt in dem fall in
brüssel bei der kommission und legt die
teilnahme an dem kartell auf und offen
und gibt weitere informationen preis in
dem fall war das immer ein im jahr 2011
wenn ich mich nicht täusche und hat also
dargestellt dass mindestens ab 19 97
es geht über verschiedene staffeln
hinweg eine ist unter anderem bis 24
dann später geht es dann auch noch
weiter mit absprachen das also
absprachen zwischen diesen bereits
erwähnten kreis von herstellern
stattgefunden hat das dann also
listenpreise deutlich höher dargestellt
worden
wir reden also über nutzfahrzeuge renova
lkws und wir reden auch über
fahrzeuggestelle und in dem konkreten
fall ist eigentlich das spannende das
wird es nicht über ein produkt reden
dass klassischen nv betrifft sondern das
betrifft speditionen andere unternehmen
das betrifft viele unternehmen aus der
produzierenden industrie aber auch in
kommunen und so ist es auch hier also
eine sehr breite und diversifizierte
käuferschaft vielleicht erstmal zu den
unmittelbaren und einem anschluss zu den
mittelbaren auswirkungen dieser
offenlegung durch ma lin immerhin selber
war glaube ich fein raus indem sie diese
grundregel regelung in anspruch genommen
haben mussten sie keine kartell strafe
entrichten die anderen unternehmen aber
schon wichtig war dass es recht also die
folge dieser sanktionierung ist das
natürlich die gewährten würde erstmal
eine untersuchung an deren ende dann
eine sanktionierung steht der kronzeuge
kann also je nachdem wie gut die
information sind und wie viel dazu auch
beitragen dass weitere illegale
handlungen aufgedeckt werden kann da
eine reduktion stattfinden der geldbuße
bisher gegen null also in dem fall kann
ohne eine geldbuße und der strafzahlung
der davon
insgesamt hat die eu kommission dann
in den verschiedenen sondern zwei
staffeln fast vier milliarden an
bußgeldern verhängt größten anteil ging
auf daimler die letzten die jetzt noch
geld bekommen haben war im letzten jahr
scania war es kann hier hat sich da
nicht sehr kooperativ gezeigt der
aufklärung beizutragen und klagt jetzt
auch gegen diese geldbuße interessanten
das werden wir weiter verfolgen aber
jedenfalls soweit ist einmal en betrifft
da waren sie also raus aber die wirkung
der grund zeugen regelung ist natürlich
nicht dass sie deshalb auch von
schadensersatz klagen einzelner käufer
verschont blieben das könnte ja auch gar
nicht sein das wäre dann ja quasi eine
regelung zu lasten dritter
und tatsächlich ist es jetzt auch dazu
gekommen das geklappt hat und erfolg
hatte
vollkommen zu recht denn wie du ihm
schon gesagt hast das eines das
verhältnis das karte lang zu behörde das
anderes aber dann die zivilgericht die
vereinbarung die letztendlich auf den
kaufvertrag tritt in dem fall der jetzt
also vom landgericht hannover kurz vor
weihnachten schon entschieden wo dann
jetzt erst bekannt wurde geht es um eine
klage der stadt göttingen statt götting
hat weder andere kommune fahrzeuge
dieser brauch zur erfüllung bestimmter
hoheitliche aufgaben in dem konkreten
fall ist müller fuhr dann feuerwehrautos
das hat damals gab es auch früher schon
mal ein feuerwehrauto catella
fahrerkarte aber auch die vorhin schon
erwähnt fahrzeuggestelle und hat da
zwischen 2001 und 2010 bei 1 in großem
stil den fuhrpark ausgestattet
gesamtvolumen der aufträge lag bei knapp
über zwei millionen euro die machen
jedenfalls gelten auf grundlage der
jetzt bekanntgewordenen preisabsprachen
schadenersatz über 335.000 euro ist per
se wenn man dass man hochrechnet wie
viele millionen fahrzeuge wurden in
deutschland verkauft und das
multipliziert mit dem potenziellen
journalistenpreis kann der preis aber es
ist immer noch in viel geld genau die
kartell kammer am landgericht hannover
hat eine ganz interessante entscheidung
getroffen denn sie hat ein sogenanntes
grund urteil erst mal fällt also sondern
zwischen etappe im zivilprozess in dem
man dem grunde nach
ein ergebnis gewissermaßen schon
vorzieht und in dem fall ist es
besonders spannend sie haben dieses
grund total gefällt ohne die
beweisaufnahme zu gewinnen also ergebnis
forciert heißt sie haben dem grunde nach
festgestellt dass die ma lin jedenfalls
zum schadensersatz verpflichtet ist die
genaue höhe soll dann glaube ich eben
noch in einem zweiten schritt des
verfahrens ermittelt werden aber ja ohne
beweisaufnahme das ist bemerkenswert
weil sie gesagt haben das bisher schon
bekannte also ihr wart ja sogar selber
grund sorgen habe das eingeräumt das
reicht auf jeden fall aus dass er
verhaftet da brauchen wir gar nicht
weiter zu ermitteln wie wir hätten das
auch anders ausgehen können
es hätte auch anders ausgehen können
musst du erstmal dazu vor die klammer
zwischen dass hannover jetzt nicht allen
klar position recht geben wird das haben
sie auch schon gesagt wenn sind glaube
ich 13 14 fälle und eine kappe 60
prozent wird die klage erfolg haben dem
grunde nach
aber das macht das auch juristisch noch
mal so interessant für unsere hörer dann
insoweit wir hatten ja im letzten jahren
novelle des gbs und in dem gw das ja
maßgeblich den wettbewerb in deutschland
auch regelt gab es diverse umsetzung von
kartell schadensersatz richtlinien in
nationales recht und man hat da vor
allen dingen auch den unternehmen den
katalanen die möglicherweise dann auch
sich auf der klage beklagten bank sehen
ein paar mittel an die hand gegeben die
jetzt natürlich weil die beweisaufnahme
eben nicht stattfindet nicht zu tragen
kommen da werden zum beispiel dass man
die so genannte abwälzung also eine
weitergabe von überholten listenpreisen
an weitere marktteilnehmer zu lasten
eines klebers auslegen kann das muss man
das dann erst ist eigentlich eine
riesenschweinerei in der konstellation
sagt der karte land nämlich ja wir haben
zwar schon überteuerte preise genommen
aber ihrem läufer hat diese überteuerten
preise wiederum an ihre käufer
wenn man so eine kette ist weitergegeben
das ist ja eigentlich irgendwie
auch etwas fragwürdig dieser
argumentation aber das kam nicht zum
tragen hier gab es ja keine weiteren die
stadt war hände deren argument aktion
würde dann ja zum beispiel habt ihr
überhaupt ein schaden gehabt ja das ist
sie die argumentation die in der
sogenannten auch wieder ein schöner
englischer begriff passen verteidigung
der hersteller jetzt eigentlich auch ein
zentrales element sein wird in dem fall
hat die kammer aber entschieden und
gesagt na ja wir reden hier über eine
kommune die feuerwehr als auch müller
fuhr verantworten muss gegenüber bürgern
und kann denn eigentlich das eine
leistung sagen für die wir als bürger ja
gebühren zahlen die irgendwie
vergleichbares mit markt wettbewerb und
absolut und auch noch mal die das
szenario auch aufgestellt
die weitergabe der leistung musste dann
auch wieder zwischen dir und mir als
bürger im wettbewerb sorgen
aber dann ist irgendwie auch klar man
tritt hier als bürger nicht
gegeneinander leistung ebenso eine
andere kommune wo die männer vor
billiger wäre all das und dass wir beide
mit unserer mit unserem hausmüll
irgendwie in wettbewerb treten würden um
irgendwie der höheren verwaltungskreis
hätte also dass so ein bisschen weiter
gedacht und da hat die kamera gesagt nee
also das steht für uns in diesem fall
außer frage deswegen diese
abwärtsgegangen
dieser pass ohne verteidigung kommt in
dem feld nicht zu tragen und das wird
denke ich wir wissen beide dass wir
reden über eine erstinstanzliche
entscheidung inzwischen entscheidung
es ist noch keine entscheidung da es ist
auch eine höchst instanz die
entscheidung weiter nähe
aber das schaffen wir ein wichtiges
indiz auf dass andere gerichte wo die
klagen anhängig sind wir uns in viele
viele klagen anhängig waren sicherlich
schon mal schauen werden und auf dass
sich auch viele kommunen weitere
kommunen die klagen wenn noch berufen
werden ja also das ärgerlich kartell und
seine nachwehen wird uns und die justiz
sicherlich noch eine ganze weile
beschäftigen dann an meiner robert
christliche oder höchstrichterliche
entscheidung kommt dann tragen wir die
gerne nachlassens damit aber glaube ich
bei diesem thema bewenden und blicken
anschließend nach luxemburg wo morgen
glaube ich die revisionsverhandlung
losgeht gegen die beiden lux liegt
wenn man das lux wer sind diese männer
und was haben sie getan
ja wir reden hier über einen komplex der
auch wieder einige jahre zurück geht die
beiden whistleblower hinweisgeber
tippgeber das ist eigentlich dafür durch
stelle kann man alle synonym verwandt
durch als er momentan sagen wir um den
sortierung glaube ich ganz gut
der eine heißt anton latour das anderes
raphael allee beides franzosen die für
pwc oder pricewaterhousecoopers in
luxemburg gearbeitet haben
pwc nicht kennen sollte das ist eine der
großen unternehmens und
wirtschaftsberatungsgesellschaft die
global aufgestellt sind unter anderem
auch in luxemburg tätig sind und deren
spezialisierung dort ist
steuerstrukturen aufzusetzen große
unternehmen auch bei steuererklärung zu
unterstützen und so waren die beiden
auch eingesetzt anschauen der tour bis
zu seiner von ihm selbst erfolgten
kündigung im jahr 210 rafaeli noch ein
bisschen länger und ans licht gebracht
das muss man auch sagen als dritte
personen die für das strafe von morgen
aber keine rolle spielt ist eu apparat
das ist ein französischer tv journalist
der arbeitete für fonds also den
französischen staatlichen ja der ist
derjenige der das ganze dann diese
informationen in den fakten haben so
aufbereitet und präsentiert hat aber
natürlich als journalist auch als
investigativ journalist dass man eben
immer auf die informationen von insidern
angewiesen andernfalls kann man ja nicht
wissen was da so abläuft an fragwürdigen
geschäftsgebaren was lief denn in diesem
teil ab luxemburg hat
schon sehr früh sich in dem wettbewerb
steuersparmodelle positioniert damals
unter der regierung und
interessanterweise spielt jean claude
juncker jetzt ja der eu
kommissionspräsident dana sehr tragende
rolle der war zuvor erst mal
finanzminister im großherzogtum dann
später auch premier großen großherzogtum
druck und die luxemburger haben sehr
stark für die ansiedlung von
großkonzernen geworben haben
steuervorteile versprochen und jetzt
kommt da auch bbc ins spiel denn pwc war
gewissermaßen in der mittleren und
beratungs position einerseits zwischen
dem unternehmen und den dort nationalen
steuerbehörden und hat die unternehmen
betreut
bei steuerfragen und steuerklärung und
so genannten text wings und textlinks
sind vorab bescheide von finanzbehörden
wenn es denn auch um die steuerbelastung
von konzern geld muss man dazu sagen
auch in deutschland ist es nicht
unüblich dass mein steuerberater wenn
irgendwie fragen zu meiner steuer klagen
hat sich eventuell mit dem finanzbeamten
unterhält und abstimmt oder meine fragen
stellen kann aber das wäre eine
unverbindliche aber das wird und du
sagst nie die schwelle jeder jurist
versteht dass die stelle zu einem
verwaltungsakt über schreiben in dem
sich eine behörde behindert und das ist
der unterschied zu dem was in luxemburg
offenbar über jahre hinweg und auch
systematisch passiert ist es gab diese
textlinks vorab bescheid und dann
konnten die konzerne also genau sehen so
hoch ist unsere steuerbelastung hier und
wenn man eine konzerngruppe hat mit
verschiedenen tochtergesellschaften
konnte man schön die besteuerung der
gewinne dahin gehend verschieben dass
man natürlich den größten teil dann
dahin verschoben hat wo eben die
geringsten steuer eingeführt hat und das
war lux das war luxemburg weil die
wettbewerb um unternehmen betrieben
haben die wolke dass sich möglichst
viele unternehmen ansiedeln haben sich
gedacht viele stoll sozusagen viele
niedrige steuern sind besser als wenige
rohr und damit sich so ein bisschen den
diesen status einer steueroase
erarbeitet und haben den unternehmen
dann eben auch wirklich wahr ab diese
persilschein ausgestellt hat endlich
gezeigt habe wie du sagst milliarden
abgeflossen und wir reden hier über eine
gruppe von bis zu vier unternehmen um
waren ein paar namen zu nennen die auch
bekannt sind apple amazon heinz der
amerikanische ketchup-hersteller danke
pepsi auch bekannt aus funk und
fernsehen und deutsche bank ja genau und
das alles haben also diese beiden expert
pwc mitarbeiter den journalisten
zugespielt der hat das dann bricht dann
gab es eben die looks große
internationale aufregung riesenskandal
und dann gab es auch strafverfahren
gegen alle drei zunächst er selber also
der journalist ist aber freigesprochen
und wenn ich mich recht entsinne eben
klar betonungen pressefreiheit
informationsauftrag genau das ist ja
eigentlich das was journalisten tun
sollen anders ist es aber den beiden
whistleblower gerne genau in erster
instanz
wurden der tour als auch alle zu
bewährungsstrafen verurteilt
also man muss gleich mal sagen die
delikte die ihnen da vorgeworfen wurden
seitens der anklage
diebstahl verrat von berufsgeheimnis in
dem fall weil sie ja beide auch
buchhalter gewesen sind oder gewesen
waren und eindringen in die
infrastruktur man kann das jetzt im
vorgespräch gesagt nicht so eins zu eins
übertragen weil straftatbeständen die
wir dann aus dem deutschen
strafgesetzbuch kennt aber auf jeden
fall die drei sind es gewesen der tour
wurde anfang zu 16 zu bewährungsstrafen
von zwölf monaten verurteilt
dazu noch eine geldbuße von 1500 euro
alle hat weil sein beitrag offenbar vom
gericht zeit als niedriger bewertet
wurde auf neun monate auf bewährung
verurteilt wie du schon das paradies
freigesprochen worden
dagegen sind die beiden dann aber auch
die staatsanwaltschaft das ist das
spannend also ich war mit dem urteil
auch überhaupt nicht zufrieden was
sowieso auch sagen auch wurde ja hier
auch in der vaarts auch entsprechend
kommentiert die rolle des
luxemburgischen staates in der ganzen
affäre also staatsanwaltschaft wolle
sich da noch mal positioniert auch
berufung eingelegt das war dann in
zweiter instanz
da insoweit ganz spannend leichte
absenkung der bewährungsstrafen aber der
vorwurf des verrats von berufsmessen
gegen der tore fallen lassen und jetzt
wie gesagt morgen und auch kommende
woche steht die revision vor dem
kassationsgericht an
das ist höchst ein luxemburgisches
gericht das ist so vergleichbar mit den
strafsenat des bundesgerichtshofs muss
also in ihrer vision auch von strafe
zahlen geht und ja ja das ist glaube ich
ein fall wo man relativ deutlich ist
auseinanderfallen des moral empfinden
der meisten leute die ja wohl eher sagen
würden gibt den beiden orten wobei ich
glaube eine hat auch noch bekommen
das tatsächlich vom jugendparlament
ausgezeichnet wurden mit dem bürgerpreis
gut also in ordnung hatte aber eine
haftstrafe wenn auch auf bewährung hat
er eben allerdings auch ja was
wie kann man sich diesem problem
irgendwie nähern also das sind ja zwei
gegenläufige interessen einerseits
möchte man natürlich das irgendwie
kriminelle machenschaften offering
werden andererseits er hat auch das
steuergeheimnis und das und die waren
von berufsgeheimnisse sicherlich ihren
legitimen platz
es ist ein schwieriger nächstes ein sehr
spannendes thema weil es sehr
vielschichtig ist wie du schon sagst das
ja nicht in dem fall ist natürlich
steuerrecht aber müssen in so einem
kontext sehr viel über compliance reden
wir uns nur arbeitsrecht reden wir
müssen über whistleblower in schutz von
whistleblowern auto staatliche
institutionen generell mal reden das war
auch schon mal angeklungen im podcast
vor ein paar wochen hat sich über die
verurteilung von oliver schmidt das ist
dieser film ein vw-manager in den
vereinigten staaten jetzt manche sagen
als sündenbock für in der insel krk
affäre
da jetzt beurteilt worden ist zu sieben
jahren der wie wir die woche auch jetzt
mitbekommen auch klagt gegen seine
entlassung
da ist das spannend eigentlich diese
verquickung der verschiedenheit gebiete
und hier geht es für beide eher um die
patentierung im strafrechtlichen sinne
weil beide arbeiten nicht mehr für das
unternehmen
aber man muss das ganze auch immer im
kontext sehen als arbeitnehmer zu
arbeitgeber im verhältnis begehe ich
einen diebstahl verrate ich
berufsgeheimnisse verletzt sich damit
auch eine nebenpflicht und damit
riskiere ich mindestens eine abmahnung
als aber nimmer wenn ich sogar die
fristlose kündigung ja generell ist es
um den whistleblower schutz oder
anschaffen von anlaufstellen für
whistleblower in deutschland ja auch
nicht zum allerbesten bestellt was ich
sehr kontrovers für all die unternehmen
mit dem aufbau der compliance-abteilung
ja sehr viel und nicht erst seit den
bekanntesten in deutschland ist ja
siemens getan haben da wird viel geld in
die hand genommen viele auch personal
bewegt aber
die akzeptanz und vor allem auch den den
den schutz von whistleblowern das ist
wir haben mir vor ein paar monaten auch
über studie geschrieben und da kam
interessanterweise heraus dass zwar die
akzeptanz gegenüber whistleblower in
unternehmen steigt bei einer befragung
von führungskräften aber dann kam raus
und das fand ich sehr schockierend dass
immer noch 60 prozent dieser
führungskraft erwarten dass ich die
person des whistleblowers offenbar dabei
sollte gerade die anonymität oder der
letzte schutz irgendwie noch gewahrt
werden
im klassischen sinne der plätze in der
sich offenbar hat ja das wäre das
kontroverse
der sache werden sie in im januar wird
das urteil noch com lux halten wir euch
auf dem laufenden
wie die sache da aus geht machen jetzt
aber einen drastischen schwenk zu einem
ganz anderen thema das sich in
deutschland abspielt aufhänger ist das
so ein richtiges männer thema kaum dass
corinna meine ich da ist müssen wir mal
eine lanze für die männer brechen oder
ich insbesondere aber das gefühl dass zu
müssen
widersetzt sich so ein kleines bisschen
dem zeitgeist denn wenn wir über
systematische benachteiligung und
diskriminierende gesetze reden dann
denken wir dabei meistens eher in die
richtung dass frauen benachteiligt
werden oder wie man die gesetzgebung
ändern kann um benachteiligungen zu
beseitigen das ist auch alles legitim
und richtig aber das heißt eben nicht
dass das nicht bisweilen auch in die
gegenrichtung stattfinden würde so
insbesondere im familienrecht aufhänger
dieses thema ist auf denen ich dann
gleich zurück kommen werde ist eine
aktuelle entscheidung des
bundesgerichtshofs aber ich glaube um
die verstehen zu können sind erst ein
paar einleitende worte nötig ist geht
kurz um um die frage wie man rechtlicher
vater eines kindes wird es gibt ja den
biologischen vater das ist klar
derjenige der es gezeigt hat es gibt in
sozialen vater das ist derjenige der
sich einfach darum kümmert
unterhalt zeit ist zur schule bringt und
so weiter und es gibt den rechtlichen
vater das ist derjenige dem unsere
gesetz ordnung dann eben alle pflichten
zu weist aber eben auch alle rechte
umgangsrecht sorgerecht ich zeit habe
idealerweise ist alles drei dieselbe
person in der praxis aber nicht zwingend
wie wird man jetzt rechtlicher vater
entweder man ist mit der frau bei der
geburt verheiratet dann wird vermutet
dass man auch der vater des kindes ist
wenn man das nicht ist dann kann man die
vaterschaft anerkennen
und jetzt kann das natürlich zu gewissen
problemen situationen führen
beispielsweise dann wenn sagen wir mal
die frau ist schwanger geworden vom
streitet sich dann immer während der
schwangerschaft mit dem allergen
bekennen lebt mit dem zusammen der b ist
dann auch bereit sich um das kind zu
kümmern im schlimmsten aller fälle weiß
vielleicht gar nicht dass es nicht sein
es ist aber wollen das mal gar nicht
ganz aber was schloss mit dem auch das
kommt vor
dazu der rechtslage in dem fall ließe
sich noch mal eine ganz eigene sendung
führen aber lassen wir das mal außen vor
also ich jedenfalls
nehmen wir mal an der b erkennt dann
nach der geburt die schwangerschaft an
die frau lebt jetzt mit dem bild
zusammen der weg kümmert sich um das
kind der rbs also hiermit rechtlicher
vater des kindes obwohl eigentlich ja
biologisch gesehen der a der vater ist
so wenn jetzt natürlich der irgendwie so
ein rabenvater ist der diese rolle
sowieso nicht aus für den will und
heilfroh ist dass er sich nicht um das
kind kümmern muss dann ist ja alles fein
aber es kann ja durchaus auch so sein
dass der aasee ich moment mal wir sind
zwar vielleicht getrennt aber das ist
auch mein kind und ich möchte nämlich
darum kümmern ich möchte diese
paraderolle auswendig möchte
verantwortung übernehmen lieber
deutscher staat ich fechte die
vaterschaft des b an und möchte eben
selber vater sein und dann
dementsprechend alles was daraus folgt
recht auf umgang mit dem kind haben
erreicht haben sich in seiner erzählung
zu können so und diese möglichkeit das
zu tun gab es sage und schreibe bis zum
jahr 2004 überhaupt nicht ja also meine
rollen du hast du sagst grabe ich hätte
überhaupt keine möglichkeit gehabt bis
damit die position wäre recht zusichern
über ein anfechtungsrecht was ist
rechtlich sonst im bgb steht als eines
der allerersten rechts institute dass
man geld machen kann aber über verträge
jetzt hier übertragen ist unklar was
schlicht und ergreifend raus das muss
man sich übrigens um sich vielleicht
noch mal zu verdeutlichen wie
ungeheuerlich dass eigentlich ist
einfach mal in der umgekehrten
konstellation vorstellen man stelle sich
nach vorne frau kriegt ein kind
der mann nimmt das dann vom krankenhaus
zu seiner neuen freundin mit und sorgt
so hier die verdrehte babybrei und fährt
im kinderwagen durch die landschaft und
du liebe tatsächliche mutter bist jetzt
aber gar nicht die mutter hasst
dementsprechend auch keinerlei recht auf
umgang mit dem kind oder so also da
werden ja alle freund führung unter der
decke kleben und womit mit recht würde
ich sagen
und es ist aber umgekehrt eigentlich
nicht weniger ungeheuerlich und das hat
dann auch das bundesverfassungsgericht
immerhin 2004 so gesehen und gesagt ja
doch artikel 6 grundgesetz also schutz
von familie schützt eben natürlich auf
die beziehungen des biologischen vaters
zu seinem kind
deshalb bekommt er dieses
anfechtungsrecht aber
das anfechtungsrecht ist so schwach
ausgestaltet dass es in der praxis meist
in die leere läuft
und das ist letztlich zwar nicht
rechtlich aber faktisch liegt es
eigentlich bei der frau
rechtlicher vater wird also wenn wir je
nachdem wie sie die weichen stellt läuft
sein auf den einen oder auf den anderen
hinaus denn die rechtslage sieht jetzt
vor dass die vaterschaft angefochten
werden kann aber als negatives
tatbestandsmerkmal darf keine sozial
familiäre beziehung zu demjenigen
bestehen der momentan rechtlicher vater
ist also sprich wenn da schon jemand
anderes ist der rechtlich als vater gilt
und der eben eine gewisse bindung zu
diesem kind aufgebaut hat sich darum
gekümmert hat und so weiter dann
schließt das die anfechtung aus das ist
natürlich in gewissen konstellationen
auch total nachvollziehbar ja nehmen wir
mal an der ahr schwängert die frau läuft
dann wegkommt fünf jahre später wieder
inzwischen hat sich jemand anderes jahre
lang gehen soll um das kind gekümmert
und das rechtliche vater dann kann es
natürlich tatsächlich nicht sein dass
der sich jetzt auch von heute auf morgen
überlegen kann aber ich möchte seine
vaterschaft an weil ich ja biologisch
der vater bin aber so extrem muss es
eben gar nicht kommen sondern es reicht
auch völlig aus dass die frau das kind
nach der geburt erst mal zu ihrem neuen
freund mitnimmt der sicht also die
ersten monate darum kümmert ist da jetzt
keine ganz feste grenze wie lange das
sein muss sondern das ist ebenso dieses
etwas diffus merkmal der sozial
familiären bindungen ja wann genau liegt
die vor wie viel wie viel musste ja man
sich da quasi gekümmert haben und wie
lange damit er diese soziale bindung
aufgebaut hat wenn die einmal vor liegt
übrigens auch wenn sie danach wegfallen
sollte das ist egal ja es kommt nur auf
den auf den zeitpunkt der letzten
hauptverhandlung vor gericht an für
diese beurteilung dann ist man eben raus
und wenn die da die frau die er also als
biologischer vater zunächst mal einfach
den umgang mit dem kind verweigert und
das mit in ihre beziehung mit einem
anderen mitnimmt und der sich kümmert
dann werden eben buchstäblich fakten
geschaffen und diese fakten tragen dann
eben auch vor gericht übrigens als
anfechten das ist negatives
tatbestandsmerkmal das heißt du musst
beweisen dass diese bindung nicht
besteht ja nicht etwa derjenige muss
beweisen dass die besteht sondern muss
beweisen sie nicht bestehen will
vergnügen beim nachweis dessen ja wie
sollen wir denen eingefahren und jetzt
und dann komme ich zu der versprochenen
abwägung zu der aktuellen bgh
entscheidung ja also diese rechtslage
wird angezweifelt seit längerem weil
eben leute sagen das ist doch wohl etwas
arg restriktiv und hier hat jetzt einen
fall gegeben
die beziehungs konzert die konzentration
der beteiligung ist etwas kompliziert
wie beziehungen das eben und manchmal
sind so an sich haben genau aber ich
glaube wir kriegen es dargestellt
hier war es also so dass eine frau ein
kind bekommen hat
vom dann aber ein jahr lang der b sich
um dieses kind gekümmert hat und zwar
nicht mit der frau zusammengelebt hat
aber eben da täglich vorbei gefahren ist
und so dann hat sie sich vom getrennt
und kam wieder mit dem a zusammen so
inzwischen ist sie mit dem anne
verheiratet der lebt seit zweieinhalb
jahren mit dieser frau und dem kind in
einem haus der kümmert sich unstreitig
um das kind füllt die vaterrolle also in
sozialer hinsicht total aus und ist auch
der biologische vater des kindes und der
b sieht das so alle zwei wochen mal hat
so ein umgangsrecht
jetzt sollte man ja meinen also in
dieser konstellation ist doch wohl
völlig klar wer hier eigentlich der
vater sein müssen
der macht das dann faktisch und ist auch
biologisch der vater hat jetzt also
anfechtungsklage erhoben und das olg ich
weiß gar nicht genau welches ich glaube
dresden war es ja auch egal jedenfalls
das hat gesagt ja das steht zwar so im
gesetz 1600 wgs der einschlägige
paragraf nicht drin
aber wenn sozial familiäre bindung reise
zu zwei leuten besteht aber einer von
beiden ist noch dazu eben auch wirklich
bio logisch der vater und der andere
nicht ja dann muss es doch möglich sein
für den biologischen vater die
vaterschaft anzufechten obwohl dieses
kind darüber hinaus auch noch eine
bindung zu jemand anderem hat der bgh
hat eben gesagt nein gesetzeswortlaut
ist eindeutig sobald das kind irgendwie
mal in eine bindung zu jemand anderes
entwickelt hat ja eine gewisse zeit lang
anfänglich diese rolle ausgefüllt hat
ist und bleibt derjenige der rechtliche
vater und da kann man eben nichts machen
das ist klingt zwar also steht auch in
der entscheidung drin ja ob man als es
klingt so ein bisschen an dass der bgh
vielleicht selber nicht ganz glücklich
ist mit seiner entscheidung aber der
wortlaut der norm sei eben eindeutig ja
mag es du selber hast ja auch kinder
lebst in einer glücklichen ehe und
musste ich insofern mit solchen fragen
nicht herumschlagen
ich weiß nicht ob dir die gerade da
gestellte rechtslage vorher überhaupt
geläufig war aber da im gesichtsausdruck
entnehme ich dass du sie auch ein
bisschen zweifelhaft findest oder ich
finde es ein bisschen befremdlich aber
bei den sozial familiären zusammenhalt
mir fehlen da so greifbarer punkte einer
den es ja auch mehrfach angesprochen
hast gemeinsamen lebensmittelpunkt
gemeinsame wohnung
das ist zum beispiel bei der anerkennung
der vaterschaft ein ganz zentrales
element das man dann ja auch was ich
beispielsweise damals ich bin nicht
verheiratet vaterschaft anerkannt haben
in beiden fällen war das ein ganz
zentraler punkt gemeinsamen
lebensmittelpunkt
mir fehlt so etwas greifbares in diesem
sozialfall mehr
das wird das ganze auch viel einfacher
als das ist wenn man zusammenlebt dann
erfüllt dass so eine gesetzliche regel
vermutung aber ansonsten wird eben nach
solchen dingen geschaut wie einfach hat
kümmert derjenigen heraus genauso einen
neuen das muss man ja viel drauf
aufpassen macht viel arbeit und tritt er
da einfach einfach bringt derzeit mit
dem checker in sachen zu weihnachten und
so weiter das ist in manchen fällen
total einfach und eindeutig zu bestimmen
den anderen eben schwierig und wenn man
jetzt so eine konstellation wie hier hat
dessen kind eben eine gewisse bindung zu
beiden personen hat dann könnte man ja
wirklich sagen also mindestens dann
müsste doch die noch dazu gegebene
biologischen verwandtschaft eigentlich
der stechende trumpf sein ist es aber
nicht nur es gibt überdies auch
reformüberlegungen
deutsche juristentag hatte vorgeschlagen
dass ein bisschen zu lockern
ebenso eine arbeitsgruppe im
justizministerium vergangen ist ja aber
das wäre finde ich wirklich mal ein
programmpunkt der den sich dann die
kommende regierung auf die fahnen
schreiben könnte ja einer der vielen man
sich darauf die fahnen schreiben kranken
auch gerade in der rechtspolitik die
gedanke der mir kommt ist inwieweit man
da eine gewisse realität in vielen
deutschen familien stichwort patchwork
familie darstellt aber wie das eben
schon beschrieben hast es kann ja auch
die ein oder anderen missbrauch oder
unglückliche ausweitung geben wo fängt
dann diese sozial familiäre bindung an
bin ich denn tatsächlich dann nur weil
ich ständig jemanden bringen und abholen
oder auch betreue auch weihnachten und
und geschenke ansonsten vorbeibringen im
urlaub mit fahrer
mir fehlen da so ein paar einfache
scharfe konturen
das ist das was ich vielleicht noch
mitgeben möchte gut und damit
beschließen wir auch dieses ich finde
ein bisschen unerfreuliche thema und
kommen dann zu guter letzt noch ein zu
einer etwas heitere note denn auch diese
woche wie jede woche gibt es zum
abschluss der sammlung das gerechte
urteil das in diesem fall einen ganz
bemerkenswerten sachverhalt betrifft da
geht es um die klage einer kölner
beratungsfirma gegen
herren der hier mal ungenannt bleibt auf
17.000 und ein paar zerquetschte euro
wofür dafür dass sie ihn vermittelt hat
an eine um ähnliche universität die ihm
die ehrendoktorwürde verliehen hat ja
ehrendoktor muss man dazusagen
unterscheidet sich vom normalen doktor
dadurch dass er das ist dafür kein
strenges promotionsverfahren gibt dass
man durchlaufen muss sondern dass
universitäten diesen grad so ein
bisschen eigentlich nach eigenem
gutdünken verleihen können oft geht er
an leute die sich durchaus um die
universitäre lehre auch verdient gemacht
haben ein beispiel wäre der hamburger
strafverteidiger gerhard strate ja der
hat auch ein ehrendoktortitel aber der
hält eben auch tatsächlich regelmäßig
vorlesungen an der uni der hat zwar
nicht formell sozusagen er promoviert
aber der hält er vorlesungen der gibt
sehr interessante einblicke in die
praxis der strafverteidigung sowas ist
dann ja total legitim zu sagen
dem gehen wir eben ehrendoktortitel aber
nicht jeder universität legt da
dieselben standards an und dann gibt es
eben unternehmen die sich darauf
spezialisiert bindung herzustellen zu so
gewissen universitäten die da also etwas
lockerer vorgehen oder eben wirklich
aber also auch sich das ganze bezahlen
lassen und leuten die gerne einen doktor
hat sie vor ihrem namen stehen haben
wollen
das ist hier also auch alles so passiert
der typ hat diesen ehrendoktor vielen
bekommen und dann aber nicht gezahlt an
diese beratungsfirma mit dem und das
muss man sich wirklich diese
dreistigkeit muss man sich auf der zunge
zergehen lassen
mit dem argument der vertrag seien
wichtig weil sittenwidrig denn es sei ja
gar nicht um eine wissenschaftliche
leistung gegangen also er selbst sagt
quasi das war nachdem er zunächst diesen
tochter abgegriffen hat sagt dann
anschließend das ja eine riesen
schweinerei was wir hier veranstaltet
haben und das gerechte urteil ist es die
inzwischen rechtskräftige entscheidung
des olg hamm aber deshalb weil es ihnen
damit nicht durchkommen lassen sondern
es sagt
für die verleihung sei offenbar so nach
dem vortrag der parteien jedenfalls auch
eine gewisse wissenschaftlicher beitrag
von nöten gewesen also der hat da wohl
schon so ein paar unterlagen eingereicht
jetzt im detail weiß man es nicht dafür
müsste man die akten kennen
das wird sicherlich nicht gerade dem
gegenwert einer echten vollwertigen
regulären promotion gehabt haben
wahrscheinlich nicht mal annähernd aber
das gericht hat hier einen weg gefunden
zu sagen na ja also weil das so war und
weil an ihren doktor ja auch andere
maßstäbe angelegt werden können ist der
vertrag eben nicht sittenwidrig nicht
wichtig und deshalb mit freund zahlst du
wenigstens mal in die 17.800 50 euro
dafür hast du ja jetzt auch diesen titel
ja ein kurioser fall muss eigentlich
sagen die argumentation die er gebracht
hat sieht widrigkeit vom letztendlich
eine maklerin börsen etwas vermittelt
das kennen wir aus andere konstruktionen
früher war dass der klassische fall die
frauen vermittlungen in anderen ländern
zuführung an deutsche männer- und wann
sich die frage zu stellen was ist denn
eigentlich dann wieder sittenwidrigkeit
und dann auch richtig anzukommen dass
wir jetzt hier so eine konstellation
wiederhaben und er sich eigentlich durch
sein eigenes dazu wirken selbst ins knie
schießt ja ich finde ich finde man hätte
hier sonst übrigens auch noch über einen
fall des von treu und glauben nachdenken
können natürliches verhalten denn erst
den vertrag einzugehen den man selber
für sittenwidrig hält und ihn dann nicht
zu bezahlen mit dem argument da so
sittenwidrig sei das müsste ich jetzt
noch mal in ruhe durch prüfen aber das
könnte ja eventuell sonst auch noch
einen einwand sein der dann zur
zahlungspflicht letzten endes aber es
wird letztendlich wieder die letzte
keule gewesen wie man wohl ich glaube
nicht mehr ich glaube dann muss man
tatsächlich erfolg nehmen das ist dann
ich kann mich noch aus dem ausnahme
skript zum studienzeiten erinnern wenn
zwei schweine sich um die wurst streiten
gewinnen dass die energie dass sie mal
hat also sozusagen wenn man die zahlen
schon bekommen hat muss man sich zurück
erstatten aber umgekehrt kann man sich
nicht einklagen meine ich aber das soll
jetzt kein rechtsstaat an dieser stelle
seien wir hoffen sowieso dass ihr aber
ich kenne ehrendoktortitel kauft das ist
auch alles herzlich alba und wir haben
auch keine bewerbung auf den doktortitel
dann zu guter letzt noch ein ganz kurzer
nachtrag und hat eine zuschrift erreicht
zur letzten sendung wo jemand ein
kleines detail richtig gestellt hat
allerdings ums geld transparenzgesetz
corinna sagte es würde aus einer
vergleichsgruppe von sechs kollegen der
medianwert der gehälter ermittelt das
ist ein statistischer terminus und
insofern nicht ganz richtig was
ermittelt wird ist der mittelwert also
sprich sechs gelder werden auf addiert
und durch sechs geteilt das was dabei
rauskommt ist die auskunft über das
vergleichs gehalten und erhält medien
ist ein bisschen was anderes müssen wir
jetzt nicht im detail darlegen ist auch
wirklich nur eine kleinigkeit aber wir
freuen uns natürlich immer wenn
aufmerksame hörer und auch auf solche
dinge hinweisen wie wir uns überhaupt
über feedback freuen dass ihr gerne
loswerden könnte wahlweise an faz
einspruch faz.de oder auf twitter da
sind sowohl grüner budras als auch
markus jung als auch ich selber
vertreten und freuen uns über eure
anschriften dann bleibt uns zu guter
letzt nur noch zu sagen es wäre falls
euch die sendung gefallen hat und der
podcast überhaupt gefällt wäre es ganz
toll wenn ihr uns auf itunes eine
bewertung geht
das bringt uns ungemein nach vorne dann
wird der podcast prominente ausgespielt
mehr leute sehen den mehr leute hören
denen die welt wird ein besserer ort und
ich glaube damit sind wir am ende
angelangt mehr weiblich mehr zu tun als
dir zu danken lieber markus für dein
ganze wundervollen einsatz war bisher
immer ein sehr treuer hörer der sendung
und ich finde auch ein ganz wunderbarer
sprecher es würde mich freuen sich bei
passender gelegenheit hier wieder mal
vielen dank konstanz hat spaß gemacht
ich denke dass wir uns bald wieder hier
in dieser konstellation gegenüber mit
dem mikrofon dann mit
sehen ich wünsche den hörern des
podcasts viel spaß mit der folge und
allen weiterhin eine gute woche
natürlich bis nächste woche dann in der
konstellation constantin und corinna ist
ein